l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi portant
mesures d'urgence pour la protection du
pouvoir d'achat
la parole est à madame aude région
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre
madame et messieurs les présidents de
commissions et chers collègues c'est
avec une grande satisfaction que je vous
présente aujourd'hui les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi portant mesures d'urgence
pour la protection du pouvoir d'achat je
me félicite que l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat et travailler ensemble dans un
esprit constructif et de compromis ce
texte pour ainsi être promulgué dans les
meilleurs délais et bénéficier
rapidement à tous nos concitoyens je
voudrais le salut est d'abord le travail
de l'ensemble de mes collègues
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale
charles charlotte parmentier le coq et
sandra marsault ainsi que de nos
collègues rapporteur au sénat frédérique
puissat daniel grémillet et bruno belin
je me contenterai ici d'évoquer les
points saillants du texte adopté en cmp
dans un contexte inédit de reprise de
l'inflation le titre 1 vise à protéger
le niveau de vie des français il fallait
d'abord répondre à une situation
d'urgence en particulier pour nos aînés
et les personnes les plus fragiles les
retraites les prestations familiales et
les minima sociaux seront donc
revalorisé de 4 % dès cet été cela
représente un effort budgétaire massif
de 8 milliards d'euros à la hauteur des
attentes de nos concitoyens
porté par une quasi unanimité des
groupes politiques la dea conjugale
isation de l'âge constitue une avancée
majeure en faveur de l'autonomie de nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap ce
texte porte également l'ambition
d'améliorer durablement le partage de la
valeur dans les entreprises l'article
1er pérennise la prime de pouvoir
d'achat renommée prime de partage de la
valeur et trible son plafond
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la république
l'article 3 assoupli le cadre juridique
de l'intéressement afin de favoriser sa
diffusion dans les petites et moyennes
entreprises et l'article 3 bis permet
aux salariés pour un temps limité de
débloquer par anticipation les sommes
distribuées au titre de la participation
et de l'intéressement pour l'achat de
biens et de services
en outre nous prenons des mesures
concrètes pour que le travail soit
reconnu à sa juste valeur les pme
bénéficieront d'une déduction
forfaitaire de cotisations sociales au
titre des heures supplémentaires
effectuées par leurs salariés
l'allègement de cotisation pour les
travailleurs indépendants dans les
revenus sont proches du smic permettra
d'augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat de 550
euros par an en matière de logement les
dispositions sont conservés dans leur
écriture du sénat qui avait rétabli la
plupart des évolutions décidées au sein
de l'assemblée nationale sur le titre 2
relatif à la protection du consommateur
nous nous sommes efforcés de concevoir
des dispositifs opérationnels pour les
consommateurs ainsi que des obligations
proportionnée pour les entreprises nous
avons amélioré le dispositif du bouton
résiliation utilisable pour les contrats
de consommation et des contrats
d'assurance
l'exercice du droit de résiliation de
contrats de service qui importe au
quotidien est facilité par exemple pour
les abonnements de téléphonie et
d'internet
sur le titre 3 enfin pour lequel duquel
j'avais la charge relatifs à la
souveraineté énergétique nous avons
précisé l'encadrement des dispositions
visant la sécurité à sécuriser notre
approvisionnement en gaz dans un
contexte de haute tension pour l'hiver
prochain un compromis a ainsi été trouvé
sur la durée d'application de l'article
12 donc article qui permet à l'état de
réquisitionner ont besoin les centrales
à gaz et qui sera limitée à 4 ans
maximum
l'assemblée nationale a par ailleurs
limité la durée d'exploitation du
terminal méthanier flottant du havre à 5
ans infrastructures gazières non
pérennes disposition votée conforme au
sénat et nous avons par ailleurs
conserver les apports du sénat qui
renforce la maîtrise des conséquences
environnementales de l'installation sur
l'article 16 nous avons conservé les
compléments du sénat concernant
notamment des sanctions associé à
nouvelles obligations de compensation
incombant aux exploitants des centrales
à charbon en contrepartie leur reprise
temporaire d'activité ainsi que
l'exigence que les projets de
compensation soit bien situés sur le
territoire national des compromis ont
également été trouvées sur plusieurs
articles additionnels introduit par le
sénat pour protéger nos concitoyens fera
lee fragilisé par la flambée des prix de
l'énergie le 15 quater interdira de
couper l'électricité des résidences
principales en cas d'impayés sans être
passé par une phase de réduction de
puissance préalable d'un minima un mois
quant à l'article 19 ter nous
demanderons un rapport au gouvernement
sur la situation des collectivités
territoriales face à l'emballement des
prix de l'énergie et sur les leviers
possibles pour encore mieux les
accompagner
enfin les articles 20 26 et 21
traduisent des dispositifs visant à
soutenir la décarbonation du transport
routier face à la hausse du coût des
carburants en conclusion et eu égard à
ce travail de collaboration rapprochée
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
remet je vous invite à adopter ce texte
qui propose des solutions ambitieuses et
concrètes face à la hausse des prix qui
pèse sur nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
merci à porter la parole est à monsieur
olivier dussopt pts ministre du travail
du plein emploi et de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président la
commission des affaires économiques pas
d'âme la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les députés avec une espagnole
une hache ministre la transition
écologique nous sommes transition
énergétique pardonnez moi nous sommes
particulièrement heureux de vous
retrouver pour les lectures de
conclusions d'une commission mixte
peuple d'une commission mixte paritaire
positive permettant si vous en décidé
d'adopter le texte portant diverses
mesures d'urgence pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des français il était
urgent d'agir urgent de le faire avec
des mesures concrètes et je crois que le
texte que nous vous proposons cet après
midi permet justement d'apporter des
réponses à nos concitoyens c'est ce que
nous faisons en avançant les
revalorisations des prestations sociales
privées au 1er janvier au 1er avril
prochain
l'ensemble des prestations augmentera de
4 % et cette revalorisation vient
s'ajouter à celle de 1,2 pour cent a
acté le 1er janvier dernier et celle de
1,8 pour cent du 1er avril dernier cela
concerne entre autres les minima sociaux
mais aussi la prime d'activités ainsi
sur ce sujet nous démontrons une volonté
sans aucune ambiguïté en n'opposant pas
la valeur du travail et le soutien de
concitoyens les plus fragiles c'est ce
que nous faisons aussi avec ce texte en
proposant à l'article 3 de favoriser le
recours à l'intéressement en particulier
pour les petites et les moyennes
entreprises en prévoyant par exemple des
modalités simplifiées de mise en oeuvre
et une simplification de la côte de la
validation des accords d'intéressement
c'est ce que nous faisons aussi en
prévoyant une diminution des cotisations
des travailleurs indépendants avec une
baisse pérenne qui se traduira par un
gain de pouvoir d'achat pour aller
jusqu'à 550 euros pour les artisans
commerçants et les professions libérales
rémunérés au niveau du smic les micro
entrepreneurs bénéficieront d'un
dispositif adapté à leurs spécificités
et je précise à nouveau devant vous
cette exonération sera compensée à la
sécurité sociale par l'état ces trois
mesures sont particulièrement
importantes mais elles sont loin d'être
les seuls du texte et lorsqu'on
considère l'ensemble personnes par un
pays en tout cas en europe ne fait
autant pour le pouvoir d'achat de ses
concitoyens nous le faisons depuis le
début de la crise pandémique nous le
faisons depuis le début de la crise
inflationniste en mobilisant avec ce
texte est le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif en cours d'examen plus de
20 milliards d'euros pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
ces trois mesures ne sont pas l'unique
apporte ce texte qui symbolise aussi une
autre chose la co construction dont nous
avons presque tous super preuves sur les
bancs de cette assemblée au sénat pour
parvenir à des compromis ce texte a
effectivement fait l'objet de compromis
je sais pertinemment et le gouvernement
sait que rien n'est dupe iql rien n'est
jamais duplicable mais cela peut aussi
avoir valeur d'exemple pour des textes
qui seront soumis prochainement à votre
examen le compromis a été au rendez vous
par exemple pour la déconvenue gallisa
sion de l'allocation adultes handicapés
cdh et conjugale isation est le fruit
d'un amendement commun de bon nombre
d'entre vous lors de l'examen du texte
en première lecture et il entrera en
vigueur au plus tard le 1er octobre 2023
l'examen parlementaire et les travaux en
particulier du sénat ont aussi permis
d'introduire la pinte la possibilité
d'un déblocage anticipé de l'epargne
salariale à hauteur de 10000 euros pour
l'acquisition de biens ou de fourniture
de services et ce jusqu'au 31 décembre
de cette année aussi je me réjouis de
l'accord trouvé en cmp sur les 5
premiers articles sur le titre 1 et je
souhaite revenir simplement sur trois
points tout d'abord la pérennité de la
prime de partage de la valeur pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés qui a
été conservé à l'issue de la cmp c'est
un signal important en terme de
lisibilité de long terme pour les
entreprises et les salariés qui vont en
bénéficier
cette prime de manière générale
rencontre un franc succès et nous
pouvons ainsi la concrétiser un des
engagements du président de la
république sur ce sujet des primes je
sais que le sujet des intérimaires a pu
amener les inquiétudes sur les bancs de
l'assemblée comme du sénat je tiens donc
à rassurer l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale sur le fait
qu'en application du principe à travail
de valeur égale salaire égal la
rémunération du travailleur temporaire
ne peut être inférieure à celle que
perçoit chez l'utilisateur et a préparé
deux décès un salarié de même
qualification occupant le même poste de
travail en conséquence si l'entreprise
utilisatrice de travailleurs
intérimaires décide de verser la prime
de partage de la valeur à ses propres
salariés les travailleurs temporaires en
mission dans l'entreprise utilisatrice
percevront bien la même prime et dans
les mêmes conditions celle ci sera
versée par l'entreprise de travail
temporaire qui assure le versement de la
rémunération du travailleur temporaire
qui ensuite l'art facturera à
l'entreprise utilisatrice
par ailleurs une entreprise de travail
temporaire pourra aussi verser la prime
temps à ses salariés permanents car ces
salariés mis à disposition ou en
intermission une instruction
ministérielle viendra confirmer très
prochainement ses modalités
d'application et permettre ainsi la plus
grande clarté par ailleurs là aussi
c'est le fruit de la cmp l'article 4 qui
permet d'engager la restructuration des
branches professionnelles disposant de
minima conventionnels durablement
inférieurs au smic a été rétablie sans
préjuger de dialogue social en
entreprise qui reste piliers des
négociations salariales c'est un levier
d'action supplémentaire pour empêcher
des blocages durable et qui apparaissent
ici ou là et qui peuvent inciter les
branches à rester très mobilisés
notamment une période où le smic
augmente régulièrement du fait de la
seule inflation enfin des heures
supplémentaires bénéficieront d'une
nouvelle exonération de cotisations
exonérations forfaitaire de cotisations
sociales patronales pour les entreprises
de 20 à 250 salariés ce sont là autant d
éléments du compromis qui permette
l'aboutissement de cette commission
mixte paritaire aboutissement dont nous
nous félicitons et avant de céder la
parole à ma collègue un espagnol une
hache et je tiens simplement à préciser
à l'assemblée nationale que trois
amendements ont été déposés par le
gouvernement en accord avec les
rapporteurs de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat trois amendements qui
permettent de lever le gage sur un
certain nombre de dispositions adoptées
par le parlement et ainsi de garantir la
bonne mise en la bonne mise en oeuvre du
texte
merci
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nash ministre de la transition
énergétique
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame et
monsieur les présidents de commissions
mesdames les rapporteurs charlotte
parmentier sandra marsault et mode
brégeon mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous arrivons au terme de
l'examen de ce texte en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat des français après plus
de trois semaines de débats nourris je
crois que nous pouvons collectivement
salué l'adoption de ce texte qui
permettra un soutien direct au pouvoir
d'achat des français en particulier des
plus fragiles de nos concitoyens il est
adopté par le parlement dans un temps
record et aux termes d'un accord en
commission mixte paritaire alors que
nous vivons l'une des plus graves crises
énergétiques qui représentent 60% de
l'inflation actuelle et dont nos
concitoyens ressentent les effets
quotidiennement je salue le parlement
d'avoir pris ses responsabilités en la
matière je remercie l'ensemble des
députés mobiliser les présidents de
commission les rapporteurs en
particulier mode brégeon l'ensemble des
administrateurs et collaborateurs de
groupes mobilisés sur le texte mais
aussi les administrations dans ministère
pour trouver cet accord je lui dis ici
même nous sommes dans une course contre
la montre pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en énergie pour
l'hiver prochain avec l'adoption des
mesures du titre iii je crois que nous
donnons à l'état les leviers
indispensables pour agir dès cet hiver
je voudrais insister sur quelques
mesures de ce projet de loi et saluer
les évolutions apportées par le
parlement la faculté de réquisitionner
les centrales à gaz qui produisent de
l'électricité en cas de forte tension
sur notre réseau et nous permettent de
mieux le réguler le parlement a encadré
dans le temps cette disposition à quatre
années et préciser comment il devait
être limité pour la cogénération
ces évolutions sont le fruit de
discussions âpres avec plusieurs groupes
politiques de l'assemblée et du sénat le
projet de terminal méthanier flottant
qui est nécessaire pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en gaz pour l'hiver
2000 23 24 ans permettant d'assurer à
hauteur de 60% l'équivalent des
approvisionnements actuels en gaz russe
il a été conçu pour avoir le moins
d'impact possible sur le plan social et
sur le plan environnemental
c'est un projet temporaire et le
parlement est venu encadrer son
exploitation à cinq ans
s'agissant des coupures d'énergie pour
cause d'impayés le parlement apporter
une protection supplémentaire aux
français en dehors de la période de
trêve hivernale en instaurant une
période incompressible additionnelle
d'au moins un mois avant que la coupure
de courant ne soit effective au cours de
cette période la puissance mise à
disposition sera réduite aux usages
électriques de base cette période vise à
accompagner plus efficacement la
recherche de solution entre fournisseurs
et consommateurs comme je lé indiqué
hier aux questions au gouvernement je
demande aux services de l'état d'être
extrêmement vigilant dans la mise en
oeuvre de ces coupures afin que tous les
acteurs sociaux notamment soient
préalablement informer pour mieux
intervenir auprès des publics en
difficulté enfin je salue l'adoption des
mesures visant à sécuriser le
rehaussement du plafond de la reine de
21 water nous sommes arrivés à un
compromis qui sécurisera la protection
des entreprises bic trop intensive et
des collectivités territoriales face aux
hausses de primes énergie en 2022 en
parallèle l'état affirme plus que jamais
le caractère stratégique d'edf avec sa
participation à l'augmentation de
capital en avril dernier et
prochainement la montée à 100% du
capital de l'entreprise le texte apporte
également des avancées notoires en
matière de protection des consommateurs
elles ont été portées dans le titre 2
par les ministres olivia grégoire et
olivier klein que je vous prie d'excuser
pour leurs absences il permet la mise en
oeuvre de boucliers tarifaires sur les
premiers postes de dépense des français
parmi lesquels les loyers en plafonnant
à 3,5 pour cent l'augmentation de loyer
alors qu'elle aurait pu atteindre près
de 6 % ayant raveurs revalorisant de 3
5% les aides personnelles au logement
pour protéger nos concitoyens qui en ont
le plus besoin le gouvernement se
félicite de la mesure qui a été adopté
au sénat et suite à l'alerté à la
mobilisation des députés sur le
plafonnement de l' indice des loyers
commerciaux
grâce à ce travail des parlementaires en
lien avec les représentants des
bailleurs et des commerçants nous
plafonnerons durant un an la hausse des
loyers commerciaux des pme à 3 5% nous
rendons le consommateur maître de ses
choix et de ses dépenses c'est tout
l'objet du bouton résiliation mise en
place pour les abonnements du quotidien
et les contrats d'assurance et mutuelles
encore grâce au travail des
parlementaires nous élargissons le
périmètre de ces dispositifs les
consommateurs pourront résilier
facilement en ligne leur contrat dès
lors que l'entreprise dispose d'un mode
de souscription en ligne c'était une
demande venue de vauban nous en tenons
compte tout en protégeant les plus
petites entreprises les modalités de
commercialisation des assurances
affinitaire comme les garanties pour les
téléphones propre portable ou
l'électroménager seront fortement
encadrée afin de mieux protéger le
consommateur
certains frais d'incidents bancaires
seront également mieux encadrer afin de
renforcer la protection des plus
vulnérables
il s'agit d'amendements venue des deux
assemblées qui ont enrichi le texte
enfin ce texte renforce l'arsenal des
sanctions et de moyens de contrôle et de
communication sur ce que comini moment
communément nous appelons les arnaques
au rythme de développement de celle-ci
par le biais d'internet notamment notre
responsabilité est de mieux protéger les
français lorsque l'on sait par exemple
que le préjudice estimé dans le cadre
des plaintes pénales de fraude aux
comptes personnels de formation entre
mars 2020 et mars 2022 ''environ les 27
millions d'euros la nécessité d'agir
directement pour protéger les français
en renforçant notre arsenal de lutte
contre ces pratiques déloyales n'est
plus à démontrer je vous remercie
merci madame mise
madame rousseau pour un rappel au
règlement sur quel fondement s'il vous
plaît
nantes
la présidente merci pour ce rappel au
règlement au titre de l'article 70 sur
la discipline l'immunité et la
déontologie
hier j'ai posé une question au
gouvernement sur la sur la variole
simiesque dit la variole du singe au
moment où j'évoquais la honte que
subissaient les patients atteints de
cette maladie
monsieur aurélien pradié et c'est noté
dans le compte-rendu s'est exprimée en
assemblée c'est surtout une honte pour
les singes je demande donc à ce qu'il y
ait des excuses publiques et que le cas
soit étudié
et que le cas soit étudié en conférence
des présidents afin qu'une sanction soit
prise au titre de l'homophobie manifeste
de s'être main
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame rousseau
mamou son jeu je prends acte de ce que
vous venez de dire est qu'il sera
transmis au bureau de l'assemblée nous
poursuivons s'ils voulaient bien mes
chers collègues j'ai reçu de ma table de
madame mathilde de panneaux s'il vous
plaît j'ai reçu de madame mathilde de
panneaux et des membres du groupe la
france insoumise nubes une motion de
rejet préalable déposé en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à madame aurélie trouvé pour
une durée de 10 minutes maximum
[Applaudissements]
bien madame la présidente monsieur et
madame le ministre madame la rapporteure
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi nous
proposons de rejeter ce projet de loi
d'abord parce qu il nous projette dans
un monde qui est insoutenable
insoutenable soulor sur le plan social
mais aussi insoutenable sur le plan
environnemental
c'est le monde d' emmanuel macron qui
est incarnée dans ce projet de loi et
nous le refusons un monde où s'impose la
loi du marché et où les grands groupes
privés les plus riches ont tous les
privilèges et son voit conférer encore
plus au détriment de l'immense majorité
de la population et des générations
futures
le monde des manuels macron et de ce
projet de loi c'est celui qui consume le
pouvoir d'achat de l'immense majorité
des français ce monde c'est celui des
primes macron et autres dispositifs
d'intéressement versée au bon vouloir
des entreprises est promu à la place de
hausse de revenus pérennes smic
retraite rs a rien été réhaussées à la
hauteur de l'inflation la dernière
enquête réalisée sur près de 400
entreprises en france indiquent une
hausse de salaire en 2022 de 3,1 pour
cent quand on est aujourd'hui à 6 %
d'inflation ce projet ne conduit pas à
une hausse du pouvoir d'achat c'est un
projet qui entérine la régression du
pouvoir d'achat
nous avons d'ailleurs en commission des
affaires économiques conduit une
première évaluation de l'inflation et
tous les experts considèrent qu'elle va
augmenter fortement ces prochains mois
nos concitoyens vont donc voir le plus
dur des augmentations de prix à partir
de l'automne alors qu'il faudra financer
la rentrée scolaire remettre les
chauffages en service et face à cette
inflation eh bien ce sont les plus
fragiles d'entre nous qui vont la subir
et oui puisque vous refusé de geler les
loyers et puisque les allocations
logement seront revalorisées de façon
dérisoire et ça ne couvrira même pas les
augmentations imposées par les
propriétaires
et dans ce projet il n'est même pas
possible de fixer un plafond des 100 au
prix des carburants du gaz et de
l'électricité parce que tout simplement
le marché continue d'imposer sa règle le
manque d' emmanuel macron et de ce
projet doit c'est aussi celui qui
consume peu à peu notre protection
sociale en baissant toujours plus ses
contributions sociales et donc en
asséchant nos caisses d'assurance
chômage ou de maladie le monde le monde
entier nous envie notre système social
et vous êtes en train de le réduire en
cendres demain nous le savons déjà vous
nous demanderez de diminuer encore les
droits des chômeurs et des plus fragiles
ce monde c'est le vôtre pas le nôtre le
monde des manuels macro et de ce projet
de loi c'est aussi celui qui nous verra
travailler plus pour tenter de gagner
autant c'est celui qui réduit le coût
des heures supplémentaires pour les
patrons et leur donne le loisir de
racheter les rtt de leurs salariés en
sommes et c'est assumé c'est celui qui
entendraient détruire la dernière grande
conquête sociale de ce pays à savoir la
semaine de 35 heures
et c'est celui
qui encouragera les patrons augmenter
toujours plus le temps de travail plutôt
que d'embaucher c'est donc non seulement
une loi de régression du pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi d'augmentation du chômage
le monde emmanuel macron et de ce projet
de loi c'est enfin celui qui brûle
littéralement celui qui embrase nos
forêts celui qui voit la sécheresse
enflammé notaire épuisé nos cours d'eau
et nos nappes souterraines un monde où
le climat cymbales parce que nous
refusons de prendre nos responsabilités
et d'engager la transition énergétique
elisabeth bornes nous dise est elle pas
il ya quelques semaines il faut
accélérer la sortie des énergies
fossiles et voilà que vous relancez
charbon dans le pays
le pire qui soit en matière d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
et un méthanier gazier flottant qui
remplace nos imports de gaz russe par
des imports de gaz schiste et de gaz
qatari ce projet de loi
nous entraîne dans un modèle destructeur
du climat à l'opposé de ce qu'il
faudrait enclenché urgemment
l'indépendance nationale l'efficacité la
sobriété énergétique le développement
massif des énergies renouvelables et
pour toutes ses opérations ce votre
texte des voix également les obligations
qui figurent tha la charte de
l'environnement il crée de multiples
dérogations processus d'évaluation et de
prévention des risques industriels
sanitaires et environnementaux alors que
c'est une obligation pour les autorités
publiques que d'identifier et de parer à
de tels risques vous nous demandez donc
de voter un texte qui ne respecte même
pas la base des obligations
environnementales défini depuis 30 ans
alors
alors que nous savons aujourd'hui que la
crise écologique reuver une ampleur
exigent des politiques et des choix
infiniment plus exigeants alors je vous
annonce aussi que nous saisirons le
conseil constitutionnel sur toutes ces
mesures anti écologique
et nous encourageons
les autres groupes à s'associer à cette
démarche
enfin le monde des manuels macro et de
ce projet de loi c'est celui des
multinationales qui profite à leurs
grands actionnaires et ravage les
petites entreprises comme total energy
qui a engrangé des profits records ces
derniers mois vers ce essentiellement
aux actionnaires
total énergie qui ne se verra pas taxer
ces supers profits en france alors même
qu'elle n'a payé aucun impôt sur les
sociétés depuis deux ans total énergie
qui exploitera et bénéficiera du nouveau
terminal méthanier flottant prévu dans
ce projet de loi décidément votre projet
doit est quand même très cohérent alors
vous avez rejeté toutes nos propositions
qui permettait d'augmenter réellement le
pouvoir d'achat
le smic à 1500 euros le gel des loyers
le blocage des prix de première
nécessité
même sur l'allocation adulte handicapé
que nous demandons depuis un an et demi
et bien elle ne sera mise en place qu'en
octobre 2023 en somme il n'y a pas de
compromis vous parlez de compromis mais
il n'y a pas de compromis de votre part
donc donc nous ne pouvons que rejeter un
texte de loi qui est indigne qui prépare
les français aux privations et au
renoncement à des droits fondamentaux un
logement digne et décent vivre de son
travail une alimentation saine le droit
à la santé pour tous ce monde c'est
celui d' emmanuel macron ce n'est pas le
nôtre c'est pas celui de cette jeunesse
qui nous dit changeons le système pas le
climat ce n'est pas celui des gis les
jeunes ce n'est pas celui de tous ceux
qui d'une façon ou d'une autre se bat
pour partager les richesses et pour
protéger notre planète alors ce monde
vous le comprendrez bien nous pouvons
que le rejeter
[Applaudissements]
vous remercie
je vous informe que je suis saisi sur le
vote de la motion de rejet préalable
par le groupe la france insoumise nubes
d'une demande de scrutin public le
scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale
au titre des explications de vote 2
minutes par orateur monsieur olivier
servat pour libertés indépendant
outre-mer et territoires
merci madame la présidente chers
collègues
et dames messieurs les ministres
mesdames les rapporteurs chez un
collègue au moment d'aborder les débats
tant attendu sur le pouvoir d'achat
notre groupe lionne liberté indépendante
romain territoire avait deux
préoccupations majeures
permettre à nos citoyens de vivre
dignement et lutter contre les
inégalités sociales et territoriales que
l'inflation est venue raviver sur ces
deux points le projet de loi du
gouvernement était loin d'être
satisfaisant à l'issue de nos débats
quelques avancées sont à noter et
nombreuses sont issus des propositions
des différents groupes preuve qu'il
faudra faire preuve de davantage d coûte
à l'avenir et composer avec les
oppositions
notre groupe s'est battu et a réussi à
inscrire dans ce texte des mesures
d'adaptation aux spécificités
territoriales qui manquait cruellement
nous nous félicitons particulier de
l'adoption du bouclier loyers aux
outre-mer et à la corse grâce à nos
amendements la hausse des loyers sera
contenue dans ces territoires très
exposées à la cherté de la vie
d'autres motifs de satisfaction sont à
soulever la dea conjuguer lisation du
calcul de l'allocation adulte handicapé
qui est une victoire collective est une
mesure de justice sociale
mais aussi la revalorisation des
prestations sociales et des pensions de
retraite c'était une nécessité
et bien le minimum pour ces raisons
notre groupe ne peut pas voter cette
motion de rejet nous ne pouvons en effet
pas renoncé à quelques avancées
tangibles et concrètes pour autant nous
leur disons le projet de loi ne règle
pas tout la situation de grand nombre de
nos citoyens et de nos territoires sont
fragiles et le resteront sans effort
supplémentaire sans propositions
nouvelles et surtout pérenne je vous
remercie
je vous remercie pour le groupe horizon
et apparentés monsieur thomas l'unil
merci madame la présidente
écoutez après ce discours marqué par les
dogmes que nous connaissons bien avec la
france insoumise finalement c'est un
élément de clarification s'il en était
nécessaire pour rappeler que la france
insoumise rejette donc la pérennisation
et le triplement du plafond de la prime
macron la france insoumise rejette la
parole à parrot bord isation de
l'intéressement la femme la france
insoumise rejette le déblocage de
l'epargne salariale la france sam
soumises rejette le rehaussement du
plafond de défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la panse insoumise
rejette la conversion des retraités en
salaire la france insoumise rejette la
revalorisation des allocations
familiales des retraites et des minima
sociaux la princesse ou mises rejette la
revalorisation des apl la france
insoumise rejette la prolongation du
bouclier arrivèrent sur le gaz et
l'électricité jusqu'à la fin de l'année
au final la france insoumise rejettent
les mesures allant donner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français donc la majorité
soutient ces mesures rejettera à cette
notion est votre a très largement ce
texte
je vous remercie
pour le brou démocrate modem et
apparentés monsieur bruno myle yens
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur ministère collègues
nous rejetterons bien évidemment cette
motion de rejet parce que là le fait que
vous l'ayez poser je vais vous dire les
bras m'en tombent vous nous refaites le
coût de ce qu'avait fait mélenchon au
début de la précédente législature la
république c'est moi vous nous faites
la démocratie c'est nous mais vous
n'avez pas été majoritaires sur ce texte
il va falloir que vous appreniez il va
falloir que vous appreniez à perdre vous
avez transformé depuis que vous êtes
entré dans cet hémicycle vous avez
transformé cet hémicycle en un théâtre
permanent pour youtube heures et ça
c'est inacceptable
en posant cette motion de rejet en
pesant cette motion de rejet vous
déshonorez les travaux du parlement nous
avons construit ses lois vous n'étiez
pas d'accord avec nous mais ça a été co
construit avec différents groupes vous
déshonorez tous ceux qui nous ont
précédés ici ici c'est la chambre de la
démocratie vous n'êtes pas la démocratie
loin s'en faut votre vision du monde ne
sera jamais la nôtre parce que la
démocratie ne la partageons avec tout le
monde et nous ne restons pas dans
l'antre soit un dernier mot pour dire
pour parler au nom des nouveaux députés
qui sont entrés dans l'hémicycle et qui
sont venus me voir très nombreux ils
m'ont dit dans quel monde de fous nous
sommes rentrés nous étions nous étions
tous des élus locaux au service de notre
citoyens travaillant pour l'intérêt
général et on se retrouve au petit
théâtre de bouvard avec des gens qui ne
soignent qu'une chose leur chaîne
youtube ces gens là se demande ce qu'ils
font ici par respect pour eux par
respect pour les travaux qui ont été
menés dans cet hémicycle et au sénat par
la conclusion de cette cmp conclusive
vous devriez avoir honte de poser cette
motion mme roger donc nous la rejetons
avec force
remercie
pour le groupe le républicain monsieur
thibault bassin
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente madame et
monsieur le ministre madame et monsieur
les présidents de commissions madame à
la rapporteure le groupe de la france
insoumise nous propose par cette motion
de rejet de rejeter en bloc ce projet de
loi portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat si une
telle motion venait à être adoptée alors
que les français attendent des mesures
depuis des mois face à cette inflation
cela viendrait les compromettre ce n'est
pas acceptable car ce qui est
insoutenable
c'est votre motion soyons responsables
et à la hauteur des attentes des
français l'inflation est à 1 et un
niveau inédit depuis 40 ans il faut y
apporter des réponses il y a urgence à
adopter des mesures pour améliorer le
conte le quotidien de nos concitoyens
même si j'en conviens elles sont
insuffisantes et incomplètes mais soyons
sérieux responsable les insoumis comment
pouvez-vous rejeter un projet qui
revalorise les pensions de retraite
alors que nos retraités subissent de
plein fouet l'inflation comment
pouvez-vous rejeté un projet qui
revaloriser les allocations familiales
comment pouvez-vous rejeter un projet
qui améliore le pouvoir d'achat des
travailleurs indépendants aux revenus
modestes comment pouvez-vous rejeté un
projet qui va protéger davantage les
consommateurs
car il ya urgence mes chers collègues à
adopter ces mesures il y a urgence pour
redonner du pouvoir d'achat face à cette
inflation galopante c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre groupe en responsabilité
des républicains rejettera cette motion
de rejet
je remercie
ma parole et à monsieur zidane chose
pour le groupe renaissance
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres chers collègues nous groupe
renaissance nous opposerons bien entendu
à cette motion de rejet et nous
également nous ne la comprenons pas ce
texte est le fruit d'un mois de travail
il est le fruit d'un bon compromis entre
plusieurs groupes de notre assemblée et
il est surtout le fruit d'un compromis
d'un excellent compromis avec le sénat
ce texte illustre donc ce que les
français veulent de nous et qui est le
message qui nous a été envoyé lors des
élections législatives
ils veulent que nous travaillons
ensemble et que nous construisions des
compromis raisonnables et que nous ne
fassions pas ce que l'extrême gauche
fait encore aujourd'hui de l'obstruction
systématique
pour entraver les travaux aient empêché
d'améliorer le quotidien des français
face à l'inflation il ya urgence d'agir
agir pour pérenniser la prime de partage
de la valeur agir pour baisser les
cotisations des travailleurs
indépendants agir pour simplifier les
accords d'intéressement pour revaloriser
les retraites la prime d'activité les
apl les minima sociaux les prestations
familiales les bourses étudiantes la
parole est alors attaria du self hadji
est bondée conjugale izella lui
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui a été
le fruit d'un excellent compromis là
aussi trouvé ici agir pour sécuriser nos
stocks de gaz et créer un stop un
terminal méthanier flottant pour assurer
là aussi notre indépendance énergétique
un gir pour diversifier nos sources de
biocarburants agir pour pérenniser le
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie voilà
le résultat d'un mois de travail à moi
de compromis nous travaillons ici nous
pour les français et vous collègues de
la france insoumise vous êtes là pour
faire de l'obstruction opposons nous à
cette motion de rejet et votons cet
excellent texte
vous remercie
madame rigole un gap même rigole il n'y
a pas de rappel au règlement pendant les
explications de vote vous donnera la
parole après le vote
pour le groupe les écologistes madame
rousseau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya urgence à voter cette
motion de rejet de cette loi pouvoir
d'achat
pourquoi yat-il cette urgence à la
beauté parce que dans ce que vous
appelez urgence pour le pouvoir d'achat
en fait il ya un appauvrissement des
plus pauvres puisque ce texte fait
diminuer permet de diminuer le pouvoir
d'achat des bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux que ce texte fait attendre plus
d'un an les bénéficiaires de linge pour
la déconvenue canalisations que ce texte
affaiblit de manière drastique et
structurelles le financement de notre
système social parce que ce texte vise à
importer du gaz de schiste parce que ce
texte vise à garantir les profits de
total et des autres entreprises ne
considèrent en réquisitionnant les
stocks et en garantissant les coûts par
sien ce texte permet de retourner au
charbon il faut absolument voter cette
motion censure
cette motion manger
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur kevin mon vieux
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues je vais lever un
suspense dès le début puis après je vais
vous expliquer les raisons bien
évidemment nouveau trop contre s'être
cette motion de rejet
alors c'est drôle mais on on n'est même
pas surpris en fait on n'est même pas
surpris parce qu'on sait que la france
insoumise et contre le pouvoir d'achat
des français
on l'a vécu ça fait trois semaines trois
semaines que vous êtes content mais
calme et vous ça va bien se passer vous
allez voir on n'est pas obligé de
s'exciter pour s'entendre
vous allez vous vous allez voir la
démonstration est très simple vous
depuis trois semaines à chaque
proposition que quiconque peut faire
dans cet hémicycle vous voulez ajouter
des taxes des cotisations des impôts
partout partout tout le temps alors
[Applaudissements]
alors certes
certes le projet pouvoir d'achat du
gouvernement il est nullissime on va pas
on va pas s'en cacher il est nullissime
les français attendent de payer moins
cher leur carburant ont proposé nous
pour sa de baisser la tva de 20 à 500
qu'une vraie mesures rapides et
efficaces
est ce que propose le gouvernement c'est
de laisser total se faire une grande
publicité gratuite sur le dos du
gouvernement
ça c'est une première fausse mesure
deuxième fausse mesure la prime macron
qu'on va tripler seulement un français
sur quatre ou un sur cinq touches la
prime macron ça je vous rejoins
par contre là où je ne vous rejoint pas
c'est que quand je rentre chez moi j'ai
pas envie d'avoir 20 % des électeurs qui
viennent me dire on n'aura pas la prime
à cause de vous parce que vous vouliez
autre chose et ben non c'est 20% de
français auront le droit à un petit peu
de quelque chose et au lieu de faire de
l'obstruction à tout tout le temps vous
feriez mieux de râler parce qu'il faut
râler et de le voter quand il faut voter
mais pour commencer ou bien
merci
merci monsieur louviers
nous en avons terminé avec les
explications de vote et allons procéder
au scrutin à une demande
[Applaudissements]
allez-y monsieur fin
madame la ministre monsieur ministère
collègues ça ne nous dérange pas de
passer l'été ici avec vous mêmes le
samedi et même la nuit ça ne nous
dérange pas si c'est pour le bien des
français
mais là c'est quoi c'est une loi
d'affichage
c'est une loi publicitaire nous nous
attendions à des miettes il n'y aura
même pas des miettes pour les pensées
nous sommes aujourd'hui le mercredi 3
août demain nous serons le 4 août il y à
2 133 ans que faisait nos aînés
parlementaire ici ils abolissent et les
privilèges il abolit c'est les
privilèges des seigneurs
que faites-vous aujourd'hui
que font leurs fils et leurs filles ici
il protège les privilèges il couvre les
nouveaux seigneurs en direct du g7 le
président macro ont déclaré qu'ils s'en
prendraient aux profiteurs de guerre
mais qu'avez-vous fait ici contre les
profiteurs de guerre rien total qui
affiche 10 milliards de profits aux six
mois et que faites vous ici rien total
qui ne payent pas d'impôt sur les
sociétés en france et que faites vous
ici rien voulait couvrez vous couvrez le
nouveau privilégié du ce 14 juillet le
président de la république déclaré il
faut que les français vivent de leur
travail de leur salaire c'est une des
rares fois on était d'accord mais pour
les manants pour la france qui se lève
tôt qu'est ce que vous avez prévu dans
ce projet loi rien qu'est ce qu'il ya
pour les salaires rien qu'est-ce qui a
pour le smic rien question a pour
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation rien ça signifie quoi ça
signifie qu'avec une appelation 1 6%
maintenant à 8% à l'automne les français
les français qui font tourner ce pays
ils vont se faire gratter 3 4 5 6 % de
pouvoir d'achat vol la réalité de ce
projet c'est une organisation la baisse
du besoin d'emplois
vous défendez la valeur travail dont les
mots sur vous même le jazz et dans les
villes et merci
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donc procéder au scrutin
merci de regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votants 380 exprimé
366 majorité 184 pour 76 contre 290
l'assemblée a rejeté la motion
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît un peu de calme s'il
vous plaît monsieur le ministre monsieur
mise vouliez prendre la parole je suis
navré pendant les explications de vote
et pendant le vote je ne pourrais pas
vous donner la parole je pars dans
madame la présidente mais je sais vous
qui présidait évidemment une loin de moi
l'idée de contester quoi que ce soit il
me semblait mais peut-être que je me
trompe que le gouvernement pouvait
donner un avis sur l'émotion mais
peut-être que je me trompe et si c'est
le cas je si c'est le cas j'en suis
désolé madame la présidente non c'est le
cas nous fait le gist mais avant les
explications de vote j'en prends acte
madame la présidente et et je vous en ai
je vous remercie de cette précision je
voudrais si si j'avais eu cette
information est là mais présente je me
sais je me serais exprimer je crois
pardon mesdames et messieurs les députés
que madame la présidente assure la la
police de la séance qui vient un certain
nombre de règles qu'elle a rapt et je
l'en remercie mais il me semble aussi
que lorsque le débat est ouvert le
gouvernement peut parler assez loisible
mots dès lors qu'il en fait la demande
et que la présidence de séance lui
accorde et dont je profite de cette
prise de parole pour dire que si je
m'étais exprimé plus tôt non seulement
j'aurais appelé l'assemblée à rejeter la
motion mais ces choses tête j'aurais
peut-être rappeler que jamais le volume
sonore n'a fait la pertinence d'un
propos
et j'aurais surtout dit
et j'aurais surtout dit deux choses
j'aurais surtout dit deux choses la
première c'est que c'est la première
fois que j'entends dans un hémicycle que
donner 20 milliards d'euros français cbc
leur pouvoir d'achat je crois que
lorsqu'on développe 20 milliards d'euros
pour revaloriser les minima à les
pensions pour aider les ménages fragiles
nous aidons le pouvoir d'achat et
surtout j'aurais dit aux députés qui ont
participé à l'élaboration de ce texte
qui viennent de voter contre une motion
qu'ils ont tout lieu d'être fiers d'agir
que ceux qui ont participé dans la
majorité ont tout lieu d'être fiers que
tous ceux qui dans les oppositions ont
apporté leur pierre à la construction
d'un texte ont lieu d'être fiers de leur
choix et de l'aide qu'ils ont apportée
et que ça n'efface rien des divergences
et des différences qu'on peut avoir et
je ré enfin dit que quand il ya une
urgence c'était délaisseront c est que
toutes les manoeuvres dilatoires que
vous auquel vous vous prêtez n'ont qu'un
but c'est retarder le soutien qu'on
apporte aux français
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre y avait une
demande de rappel au règlement madame
rigole
pourvu que ça concerne la tenue de nos
débats où le déroulement de la séance
tout à fait tout à fait et seulement
s'il vous plaît 70,2 comme d'habitude
madame la présidente nous avons des
débats qui sont houleux ça fait partie
de la vie de cet hémicycle nous avons
voilà
nous avons des désaccords et c'est bien
normal ce qui n'est pas normal en
revanche c'est que quatre intervenants
successifs de quatre groupes politiques
attaquent chacun nommément un autre
groupe politique avec les mêmes
arguments
madame la présidente si vous permettez
je conclus avec des citations
est-ce que je peux finir sur les
citations mais dame rigole 6 alain
rigole s'il vous plaît ce n'est pas un
rappel au règlement
ça n'est pas à l'origine à madame rigole
si ça n'est pas un rappel au règlement
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donc pouvoir poursuivre et
avant s'il vous plaît madame m garrido
un peu de cannes vous remercie avant
d'appeler le premier orateur inscrit
dans la discussion générale je vous
rappelle que pour les lectures des
conclusions de commission mixte
paritaire les interventions dans la
discussion générale valt explications de
vote
nous entamons donc la discussion
générale premier orateur monsieur adrien
cnas pour le groupe la france insoumis
denis pesce
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
s'il vous plaît merci bien vouloir
quitter l'hémicycle en silence monsieur
quatre mois vous allez là vous avez la
parole à l'isi allez-y
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres madame monsieur les présidents
de commission la hausse des prix atteint
des niveaux inédits depuis 40 ans en
france et en europe une hausse des prix
de 6 7 8 % cela veut dire une baisse des
revenus des salaires des allocations et
des minima sociaux de même ampleur pour
des millions de familles c'est la vie
quotidienne qui a rendu impossible bien
manger ou se déplacer partir en vacances
ou payer les factures et disons les
choses face à la hausse des prix vous
avez capitulé en effet vous l'avez pris
aucune mesure pas la moindre qu'il
s'attaque au mal à la racine en refusant
le blocage des prix du carburant et des
produits de première nécessité vous avez
choisi de protéger la rente privé et de
faire payer les français
le ministre de l'économie dit que
bloquer les prix coûterait trop cher à
l'état mais quelle est donc cette idée
qui voudrait que l'état garantisse la
rampe privés de grands groupes qui
réalisent des profits records et ne
payent pas d'impôts en france total
vient de réaliser 17 milliards de
bénéfices au premier semestre 2022 et
l'entreprise n'a pas payé un seul euro
d'impôt les deux dernières années dans
nombre de pays européens comme l'italie
ou le royaume uni les profiteurs de
prises les profiteurs de crise sont
taxés mais dans la france de macron les
français payent pour les actionnaires
qui se gavent et les profiteurs de crise
sont bien cajoler alors vous prétendez
prendre des mesures pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat dans un projet de loi
qui disons le une fois les comptes faits
entérine la baisse de pouvoir d'achat
des français vous débordé d'imagination
prime aléatoire au bon vouloir des
patrons défiscaliser désocialisés échec
rachat de rtt intéressement
participation une véritable loterie pour
éviter la question centrale celle des
bas salaires et la hausse du smic que
vous avez refusé en constituant une
majorité incluant la droite et l'extrême
droite la même majorité incluant la
droite et l'extrême droite qui s'est
opposé au gel des loyers et tout cela
les français doivent le savoir ils
doivent savoir que de macron à le pen on
piétine les revendications des milieux
populaires pour protéger les riches et
la rampe privé comme ils doivent savoir
que vous avez fait revoter tard dans la
nuit un amendement sur lequel vous aviez
été battue qui permettait de revaloriser
les retraites au niveau de l'inflation
que les retraités de ce pays s'en
souviennent lors de leur prochain
passage dans un bureau de vote macron et
la droite vous ont fait les poches au
coeur de la nuit
vous ne donnez absolument rien puisque
toutes les revalorisations dans ce
projet de loi sont inférieures à
l'inflation et aurait de toute façon eu
lieu automatiquement un peu plus tard le
salaire des français qui ne parviennent
même pas à vivre correctement de leur
travail n'augmentera donc pas mais que
dans le même temps les salaires des
dirigeants du cac 40 et progressé de 90
% en deux ans pour atteindre la moyenne
de 8,7 millions d'euros cela ne vous
dérange pas que les 500 familles les
plus riches de france et multiplier leur
fortune par deux sous l'action de votre
gouvernement en cinq ans pour atteindre
1000 milliards d'euros soit deux fois et
demie le budget de l'état cela ne vous
dérange pas que les plus fortes
progressions de fortune des très riches
soit comprise entre + 6 8 % et + 9 100 %
sur un an cela ne vous dérange pas non
seulement cela ne vous dérange pas mais
pire vous y participer par votre
politique vous êtes les complices du
phénomène de sécession des riches qui se
gavent et se coupe du reste de la
population qui triment et qui galèrent
vous êtes
vous êtes définitivement et radicalement
l'incarnation politique de la france
d'en haut celle pour qui tout va bien
celle qui sabrent le champagne
celle qui prend ses vacances sur le
yacht sel qui fait la fête dans les
destinations de luxe et les hôtels aux
chambres bien climatisé celle qui vit
ses rêves les plus fous sur les
cauchemars quotidien de la france
populaire et dans le même temps dehors
ça chauffe ça brûle ça crame même
troisième épisode de canicule et vous
vous rouvrez les centrales à charbon et
vous accueillez le gaz de schiste
américain au beau milieu d'un projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat vous serez
pas la cote d' alerte du changement
climatique mais celle des finances
publiques qui vous préoccupe des comptes
en bon ordre sur une planète
irrespirable voilà votre nouveau slogan
et les responsables les 10% les plus
riches vos amis qui consomme 20 fois
plus d'énergie que les 10% les plus
pauvres jassem madame la présidente aux
françaises et aux français la belgique
est tenace
merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur cats 9 n'est plus la parole
la parole est à monsieur thibault bazin
pour le groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame et
monsieur les ministres présidents de
commissions rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous voici parvenus à la fin
du parcours de ce projet de loi portant
des mesures d'urgence pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat parcours raccourci
par l'accord trouvé en commission mixte
paritaire lundi soir cet accord va
globalement dans le bon sens le texte
issu de l'accord en cmp n'est plus celui
du gouvernement mais bien celui du
parlement en effet les parlementaires
ont considérablement compléter les
dispositifs proposés le nombre
d'articles ayant plus que doublé mais
ces corrections partiels laissent
forcément un sentiment d'inachevé et
même un goût amer pour ceux qui en
attendaient plus et qui considère que
ces mesures ne sont que des rustines de
court terme car ces mesures d'urgence
demeure insuffisante il faudra demain
aller plus loin pour redonner davantage
de pouvoir d'achat à ceux qui
travaillent et à nos retraités qui ont
subi la hausse de la csg comment se
satisfaire de revalorisation à 3.5 ou 4%
quand on sait que l'inflation est
supérieure au taux annoncés ce texte a
été basée sur une inflation de 5,1 alors
que l'inflation est passée à 6,1 en
juillet outre ce fait la répartition de
ces mesures est elle juste et équitable
or là on peut mesurer une fracture au
sein de nos concitoyens comme au sein de
cet hémicycle
la question s'est même posé au sénat est
il légitime d'augmenter le rsa 2 4%
alors que l'on augmente 'l'indice des
fonctionnaires de seulement trois et
demi quel message donnons nous à nos
concitoyens
j'ai entendu nombreuses personnes durant
les campagnes électorales se plaindre du
fait qu'en travaillant ils vivent à
peine mieux quelquefois moins bien que
les personnes qui ne vivent que
d'allocations ils en ont marre de voir
adopter des chèques qu'ils ne toucheront
pas du fait des effets de seuil et cela
n'est en effet pas souhaitable c'est
pourquoi nous avons exigé et obtenu dans
le plfr une baisse des carburants pour
tous plutôt que l' usine à gaz imaginé
par le gouvernement nous les réplicants
nous voulons revaloriser vraiment la
valeur travail nous ne pouvons donc que
nous féliciter des amendements adoptés
lors de la navette suède deux textes en
cours de discussion qui conduisent à
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui
travaillent je pense à la baisse de
cotisations pour les travailleurs
indépendants au développement de à prime
de partage de la valeur et de
l'intéressement à la meilleure prise en
compte des heures supplémentaires au
rachat des rtt à l'assouplissement des
conditions d'utilisation des titres
restaurant aux déblocages anticipés de
l'epargne salariale exonérées de
cotisations voilà des bonnes mesures
adoptées grâce aux républicains les
républicains à l'assemblée au sein et au
sénat on travaillait de concert à chaque
étape du parcours les parlementaires
républicains ont ainsi pesé pour
améliorer les mesures d'urgence très
concrètement par l'exonération des
charges patronales sur les heures
supplémentaires pour les entreprises de
20 à 250 salariés nous avons diminué le
coût du travail et ainsi inciter les
entreprises y avoir recours pour mieux
rémunérer les salariés c'est le
corollaire de l'augmentation du plafond
de défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires que nous avons obtenus
dans le plfr afin que le travail paye
plus très concrètement par la réduction
du plafond des frais de résiliation nous
avons protéger davantage les
consommateurs
très concrètement par le plafonnement de
l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique à 120
térawattheures jusqu'en 2025 et l'ol
sont relève est l'heureuse maman son
prix de 46,2 à 49,5 euros par
mégawattheure nous avons renforcé la
capacité d'edf à mener les
investissements pour entretenir et
rénover le parc nucléaire on peut saluer
d'autres mesures adoptées comme la dea
conjugale isation de l'allocation pour
adulte handicapé la plus grande
protection des consommateurs la
revalorisation tant attendu des
retraites et les dispositions relatives
aux retraités agricoles élus locaux et
aux jeunes agriculteurs pour lequel nous
sommes battus à plusieurs reprises sur
le volet la sécurisation de nos
approvisionnements il est à noter que
nous payons les mauvais choix politiques
de ces dernières années il reste
beaucoup à faire pour mieux assurer à
l'avenir notre souveraineté énergétique
en confortant notre fleuron industriel
odf en produisant davantage d'énergie en
france et comment ne pas parler de la
situation économique et budgétaire de
notre pays nous sommes pris en étau
entre des mesures à prendre et un
endettement insoutenable mais là encore
nous payons le prix de l'absence de
réformes structurelles de ces dix
dernières années nous avons fait des
propositions pour faire des économies de
justice sociale par exemple en luttant
contre la fraude cela permettrait
d'économiser cinq milliards par an avec
l'instauration de la carte vitale
biométrique en responsabilité les
députés du groupe les républicains
voteront le présent texte bien
consciente de la nécessité d'aider le
français à faire face à cette inflation
soudaine mais regrettant la situation de
la france après dizaine dans dix années
de gouvernants erratique vous l'aurez
compris cela ne vaut pas un chèque en
blanc bien au contraire car il demeure
des désaccords politiques profonds avec
votre gouvernement et sa majorité vous
ne prenez pas en compte ah c'est la
réalité de nos petites entreprises et
nos territoires nous n'avons pas le même
rapport à la propriété nous dit vous
nous déplorons votre stratégie
énergétique plus nette de tes dernières
années et nous dénonçons surtout votre
laxisme et votre manque de volonté pour
vraiment lutter contre les fraudes et le
gaspillage d'argent public la france
mérite mieux que ce que vous nous
proposez depuis cinq ans les français se
méfient les uns et nous continuerons à
porter des propositions merci
la parole est à monsieur nicolas
turquois pour le groupe démocrate modem
et indépendante
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame et messieurs
mais monsieur le président de commission
mesdames et messieurs madame et monsieur
le ministre mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues depuis 2010
est le président de la république a
dessiné des objectifs de transformation
majeur pour la france notamment en
matière d'économie d'emploi en matière
de finances publiques ou en matière
d'écologie de protection de
l'environnement avec lui nous pensons au
groupe démocrate que c'est dans la durée
que nous pouvons agir de façon
substantielle sur ces sujets là il nous
faut planifier construire des stratégies
de moyen long terme pour relever les
défis auxquels la france et des français
sont confrontés mais regardez le chemin
au loin ne sert à rien s'il on trébuche
sur le caillou qui est à nos pieds et
c'est à l'image de la situation que nous
traversons sauf que ce n'est pas un
caillou mais un énorme bloc de granit
qui a surgi du fait de la reprise post
pandémie la guerre en ukraine
nous voulons du pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire pour les français par le
plein emploi la montée en compétence la
réindustrialisation c'est du moyen terme
à court terme il doit faire face à une
inflation forte qui rongent leur pouvoir
d'achat et compliquent drastiquement le
quotidien nous devions y répondre nous
l'avons fait en agissant pour tous pour
ceux qui travaillent avec l'augmentation
du smic les modalités de restructuration
dans les branches professionnelles les
heures sup le doublement ou triplement
de la prime pouvoir d'achat ou encore
l'évolution du point à 10 dans le plfr
pour ceux qui ont travaillé avec la
revalorisation des retraites de 4%
rétroactivement au 1er juillet pour ceux
qui sont les plus fragiles et les plus
modestes avec la réévaluation des apl du
rsa de l'allocation adulte handicapé
sade et conjugale isation mais aussi les
prestations familiales
pour les consommateurs en facilitant les
résiliations de contrats ou en contenant
l'augmentation des loyers
nous voulions aussi décarbonés
massivement et rapidement le
fonctionnement de la société française
en agissant sur l'isolation de nos
logements l'arrêt des motorisations
thermiques et le développement du mix
énergétique à base de nucléaire
d'énergie renouvelable c'est du moyen
terme
à court terme nous at on des mesures
d'urgence pour que tout simplement les
français puissent se chauffer l'hiver
prochain et que notre économie en
partenariat avec celles de nos voisins
européens puissent fonctionner à celles
et ceux qui poussent des cris d'orfraie
parce que nour et autorise on s'attaque
hold a fonctionné ou parce que nous
permettons la mise en place d'un méthane
est flottant nous agissons en
responsabilité car il n'y aura aucune
transformation écologique profonde
possible si le pays est bloqué
nous voulons aussi rétablir l'équilibré
des finances publiques et des antennes
et des la france c'est du moyen terme à
court terme ces 20 milliards qui sont
actés dans ce projet de loi pour limiter
les effets de la crise et notamment
celle de l'inflation car nous ne
réformerons pas la france si nos
compatriotes sont submergés par les
difficultés du quotidien
finalement et pour paraphraser un
chanteur populaire notamment auprès des
plus jeunes vouloir réformer c'est
simple et le faire avec les français
devraient être basique
déclamer des bonnes idées c'est simple
construire des majorités de projets pour
les faire adopter devra être basique
cela a été le cas et que les différents
groupes d'opposition républicain tomek
la majorité sénatoriale nous le salon et
nous en félicitons
le groupe démocrate se réjouit de ce
texte tant par son contenu que par la
forme du débat qui a eu lieu nous sommes
convaincus que cela peut être une
méthode pour la suite
garder le cap des réformes tout en
tenant compte des difficultés du moment
et travailler au delà de la majorité en
confiance et en partenariat khl sénat
simple et basique je vous remercie
je remercie
la parole est à monsieur gérard le seul
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci madame la présidente mme hedin
madame et monsieur les monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente madame
monsieur le président de commission
madame la rapporteure chers collègues le
compte n'y est pas on aurait pu avoir un
texte de gains de pouvoir d'achat ou un
texte qui permette de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat hélas nous avons un
projet de loi qui permettra simplement à
certains de limiter pendant quelques
jours quelques semaines la baisse de
leur pouvoir d'achat qui ne répondra pas
aux urgences sociales de l'automne
le gouvernement nous a présenté deux
textes un projet de budget rectificatif
et une loi pouvoir d'achat distincts
mais qui finalement relève de la même
philosophie libérale qui abîme notre
modèle social ne revalorise pas le
travail et stigmatise les personnes sans
emploi pour ce qui concerne ce texte
pouvoir d'achat c'est le texte d'une
commission mixte paritaire expéditive
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui cette
version valide la dérive libérale
impulsée par votre majorité de droite
car malgré quelques amortisseurs sociaux
c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit vous
avez délibérément choisi une cogestion
avec les républicains les mesures visant
à faire face aux difficultés
d'approvisionnement en gaz et en
électricité dans un contexte national
d'une très faible disponibilité de notre
parc électronucléaire et d'une trop
grande insuffisance du développement
dégénère méritait un vrai débat sur la
politique sur l'autonomie énergétique de
la france ce ne fut pas le cas les
travaux réalisés en commission en
lecture publique à l'assemblée nationale
ou au sénat en commission mixte
paritaire n'ont apporté finalement
aucune modification de fond au texte
initial présenté par le gouvernement
vous privilégiez une vision court
termiste qui se cantonne à trois types
de solutions largement insuffisante la
sauce indexation des prestations
sociales des bénéficiaires l'été
fiscalisation des primes versées au bon
vouloir de l'employeur et l'absence
partielle de cotisations sociales et une
croyance ce aveugle dans le marché et la
libre décision éclairée des employeurs
en fait vous ne vous attaquez pas au
coeur du problème et éviter
soigneusement les sujets principaux de
l'érosion du pouvoir d'achat des
français ces dernières années logement
mobilité chauffage alimentation vous
refusez le blocage des prix au moins
temporairement des carburants et des
biens de première nécessité pour éviter
les effets spéculatifs de l'économie de
marché vous devriez davantage régulés
pour protéger les françaises et les
français au lieu de cela nous instaurer
des augmentations de minima sociaux
qu'ils ne couvrent même pas l'inflation
attendue des primes défiscaliser
désocialisés au lieu d'une augmentation
des salaires et d'un vrai coup de pouce
au smic des heures supplémentaires à
cotisations réduites et vous prévoyez la
monétarisation des rtt et des congés
payés vous n'envisagez réellement aucun
partage équitable de la valeur créée
comment pouvez vous expliquer aux
français aux salariés que l'augmentation
des bas salaires serait impossible et
réaliste alors que certaines entreprises
dégage de forts profits et que l'épargné
qu'ovide a plus que doublé l'epargne
habituel des français en plaçant en
plaçant le versement des primes
défiscaliser comme méthode première pour
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat vous
affaiblissez notre modèle social alors
qu'il aurait besoin d'être consolidée
enfin vous avez délibérément voulu
évacuer totalement la question des
salaires et de la rémunération du
travail ce sous ce sont pourtant bien
les salaires qui permettent de valoriser
le travail et les efforts consentis par
les salariés
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec le
groupe socialiste nous défendons depuis
plusieurs mois le smic à 1500 euros net
en ouvrant également une conférence
nationale pour inviter toutes les
entreprises et tous les partenaires à en
discuter et à discuter de la juste
répartition des rémunérations au sein de
l'entreprise les principaux articles de
votre loi finalement
évite la contribution aux organismes
sociaux et en accentuant cette
fragilisation vous pourrez ensuite vous
appuyer dessus pour justifier la baisse
des droits sociaux et notamment la
réforme des retraites
est ce un test un texte de protection
non le gouvernement se contente
d'inciter les entreprises à partager
leurs profits mais les français
n'attendent pas ce genre d' incitation
ou d'incantation l'état doit réguler
arbitre est décidé et protéger quand il
ya des particuliers des entreprises qui
profitent qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
il est normal de les mettre à
contribution fiscalement et de manière
claire et sincère
ce texte ce texte est révélateur de
votre positionnement politique nous
proposions la mise en place d'une
politique en direction des français qui
en ont le plus besoin alors que vous
encourager un système inégalitaire qui
donne les clefs de politique de
restriction redistribution aux grandes
entreprises finalement ce début de
législature permet une clarification du
positionnement politique de votre
gouvernement le ni droite ni gauche est
bien loin il ne trompe plus personne ce
texte est de droite et de droite le
groupe socialiste apparentés ne pourra
pas soutenir votre projet merci monsieur
les scènes
la parole est à monsieur thomas minier
pour le groupe horizon et apparentés
madame la présidente madame monsieur lé
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques madame la
rapporteure chers collègues alors que
l'inflation devrait atteindre plus de 6%
sur l'ensemble de l'année et que la
flambée des prix percute le quotidien de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
notre responsabilité était d'agir d'agir
résolument d'agir fort et vite pour le
pouvoir d'achat mais surtout pour la
liberté des français car il n'est pas un
luxe superflu de faire le plein ou de
remplir son frigo en fin de mois c'est
un niveau de vie auquel chacun doit
avoir droit je n'en doute pas tout le
monde ici quel que soit son groupe
politique en est conscient il est
sensible le président de la république
le gouvernement et le parlement dans son
ensemble y compris ont pris cette
préoccupation à bras le corps mais pour
réussir ce n'est pas tant la simple
volonté que par la proche juste que l'on
y parvient en l'espèce la méthode
employée pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des français supposait plusieurs
choses
la rapidité de la mise en place des
mesures la méthode nouvelle de
concertation large y compris avec les
oppositions la générosité que suppose de
telles mesures de soutien et la
responsabilité dans nos dépenses
publiques cette assemblée en travail
étroit avec le gouvernement et le sénat
est parvenue à un texte équilibré entre
efficacité solidarité et responsabilité
le groupe horizon se félicite de
l'accord trouvé en commission mixte
paritaire elle est la preuve que la
co-construction parlementaire existe la
recherche du compromis aussi le besoin
de réactivité qu'attendent les français
face à l'urgence de l'inflation n'a pas
échappé aux sénateurs nous les en
remercions
nous regrettons toutefois que cette
priorité n'est pas été perçu par tous
jugeant qu'il était plus favorable à
l'intérêt des français de faire une
nouvelle fois de l'obstruction dans le
temps preuve en est la motion de rejet
est déposée par le groupe insoumis tout
à l'heure de façon objective nous
pouvons affirmer que le texte adopté par
la cmp est complet il est le reflet de
l'engagement des parlementaires des deux
chambres pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat le texte consacre et également
plusieurs mesures pour la préservation
de la sécurité énergétique tant sur sa
production que son utilisation en effet
l'interdiction des coupures
d'électricité pour impayés dans les
résidences principales des ménages
permet à chacun d'avoir accès à un
service minimum quelle que soit la
période de l'année par ailleurs
plusieurs mesures visent à mieux
encadrer le droit de la consommation
pour rendre du pouvoir d'achat je pense
notamment à la baisse des frais de
résiliation téléphonique à la
possibilité de résiliation des contrats
de services de télévision et de vidéos à
la demande en cas de changement de
domicile ou d'évolution du foyer fiscal
ainsi qu'à la résiliation en trois clics
des contrats d'assurance grâce à ce
texte
nous protégeons les plus modestes et nos
aînés en revalorisant les pensions et
les minima sociaux de 4% le la retraite
de base le revenu de solidarité active
l'allocation adulte handicapé ou encore
le minimum vieillesse bénéficieront de
cette augmentation enfin nous avons agi
pour que ce projet de loi permet aux
travailleurs d'être mieux rémunérés avec
notamment la revalorisation du plafond
de la prime macron pour enrichir les
propositions en faveur du soutien du
pouvoir d'achat le groupe horizon a pris
toute sa part entre le plfr et ce texte
sur proposition du groupe horizon il a
notamment été votée le rehaussement du
plafond de défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires à 7500 euros pour
permettre aux salariés de mieux vivre de
leur travail et aux chefs d'entreprises
de faire face à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre la possibilité donnée aux
salariés qui souhaitent augmenter leur
activité de convertir en rémunération
avec l'accord de leur employeur leur
demi-journée ou journée de rtt ou encore
l'anticipation de la revalorisation de
4% prévue au 1er janvier prochain dès le
1er septembre 2000 22 sur les tickets
restaurants et les indemnités
supplémentaires de repas
au final on regarde cet équilibre trouvé
de ces mesures concrètes pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens le groupe horizon
votera en faveur de ce texte pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français je vous
remercie
je remercie sa parole est à madame
sandrine rousseau que le groupe
écologiste du ps
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a eu guère de surprise sur ce
texte guère de surprise non plus sur ce
que vous défendez le modèle qui est ici
poursuivi est celui qui nous envoie dans
le mur comme une machine idéologique
devenue folle ce texte a puis
volontairement sur la
d'accélération la crise sociale gangrène
notre pays la peur de la relégation
la peur de ne pas pouvoir manger de ne
plus pouvoir habiter son logement d'en
être retirée au petit matin par les
huissiers nous quotidiennement le ventre
de bien des personnes leurs cris de
détresse et le plus souvent silencieux
ces personnes sont en situation de
survie chaque journée est une journée
gagner sur la pauvreté l'isolément la
peur du lendemain que proposez vous à
ces personnes n'est rien quand je dis
rien c'est rien de rien les minima
sociaux ne progresseront pas au rythme
de l'inflation certains sur ses banques
sur d'autres se sont même compromis à
vouloir les diminuer alors on connaît
votre discours il nous écoeure que les
pauvres travaillent et ils deviendront
moins pauvres c'est oublier un peu vite
qu'en france les bons points qui se sont
le plus développées au cours des années
passées sont des emplois précaires à
temps partiel et des emplois pénibles
l'entreprise donneuse d'ordre en sous
traitant puis en sous traitant de sous
traitants les chiennes s'allonge les
marges se restreignent et la pression
sur les salariés s'aggrave les salariés
du bout du bout du bout du bout ces
emplois le plus souvent invisible payés
à coup de lances pierres ne
bénéficieront d'aucune prime ils
continueront à travailler dur souvent
exposés à des produits chimiques
dangereux des postures qui abîment leur
corps ils verront sans aucun doute la
prime leur passer sous le nez alors
qu'une amende une augmentation de
salaire ça il l'attendait exit de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
les personnes bénéficiant des minima
sociaux exit aussi les travailleurs les
plus précaires les travailleurs les plus
pauvres que reste-t-il alors pas grand
chose et pour une minorité de salariés
une prime qui met en péril la protection
sociale bref des miettes
ah oui via l'allocation adulte handicapé
vous allez vous en faire des gorges
chaudes partout sans doute peut-être
oublierez vous aussi de préciser qu'elle
ne sera effective qu'en octobre 2023
pour une mesure d'urgence une urgence
qui attendra plus d'un nom une mise en
oeuvre nous avions proposé des choses
pourtant la hausse du smic à 1500 euros
refusée alors il a été proposé
l'indexation des bas salaires sur
l'inflation refusé nous avons aussi
proposé l'indexation des prestations
sociales sur l'inflation refusé face à
votre inflexibilité nous avons proposé
le gel des loyers pour limiter les
effets de l'inflation refusé refusé à
fuser par contre vous avez regardé à
droite beaucoup et souvent parfois même
vous avez risqué de torticolis vous avez
accepté les amendements off qui favorise
et encore une fois le travailler plus
pour gagner de moins en moins de salaire
différé sous forme de retraite et
d'allocations accélérer aussi notre
perte sous des tonnes de carbone
aujourd'hui nous pouvons le dire la
majorité a été trouvé à droite toute
nous aussi nous voici donc dans
l'opposition au moins c'est clair
la réalité de la discussion autour de ce
texte c'est que vous n'avez accepter
aucun compte aucun compromis aucune
évolution sur le coeur de votre projet
pour le pouvoir de vivre des français du
vent et une belle supercherie
voilà plutôt un parti social un mur
d'idéologie d'un différend de mépris
mais là ne s'arrête pas le danger ce
projet de loi permet de rouvrir des
centrales à charbon d' importer en masse
du gaz de schiste américain tout cela
pour pallier aux déficiences d'un
nucléaire à bout de souffle juste avant
de le relancer ce même nucléaire qui a
besoin d'eau alors que nos rivières sont
sains secs qui rejoindra de l'eau trop
chaude
anéantira la biodiversité des rivières
ce qui aggravera en retour le
réchauffement climatique et la perte de
biodiversité
elle est pas belle la vie en andros n
et vous le savez chaque augmentation des
émissions de carbone et de gaz à effet
de serre à partir de maintenant
demandera des sacrifices encore plus
grand pour tenir notre trajectoire de
baisse de nos émissions qui doivent
diminuer de 50% d'ici 2030 quel cynisme
alors que le giec appelle explicitement
à des mesures radicales et immédiates
pour espérer limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degré certains disaient
dont toulouse cup et bien moi je vous
dis wake up refi réveillez vous ce texte
restera dans l'histoire
ce texte restera dans l'histoire comme
le texte emblématique d'un double déni
social et écologique de ce que l'on
étudiera plus tard pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi dans une assemblée
comme la nôtre alors qu'elle savait elle
n'a rien fait vous l'aurez compris nous
voterons contre ce texte mais de
surcroît nous appellerons à une forme de
résistance contre ces dénis écologiques
et sociaux
[Applaudissements]
remercie
la parole est à monsieur pierre
dharréville pour le groupe bosch
démocrate et républicaine du ps
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
madame et monsieur le ministre chères et
chers collègues ce devait être une loi
pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est une
nouvelle loi de régression sociale la
macro ni et les républicains sont
pareils à deux minots qui passe devant
une boulangerie ils ne peuvent pas
résister
balayant l'essentiel de nos propositions
cet accord passé entre la majorité
sénatoriale et la majorité
présidentielle cette alliance des
droites ce compromis entre des forces
qui sont déjà beaucoup d'accords et qui
partagent comme cela a été dit une même
philosophie n'est pas une surprise mais
elle n'en est pas moins g une nouvelle
fois ou fait semblant de prendre de
bonnes mesures mais pour de bon au delà
de celles qui relèvent du service sous
minimum et de la dea conjugale isation
de la hache qui était inéluctable
tardive mais inéluctable vous en prenez
beaucoup de mauvaises et vos intentions
se précise au fil du parcours du texte
il est temps d'en dit mettre fin on ne
sait pas jusqu'où il pourrait aller
encore il nous revient du sénat ainsi
encore plus régressif j'en veux pour
preuve la gourmandise des républicains
laquelle vous avez cédé et qui installe
de manière pérenne les dispositifs
d'encouragement à la pratique des heures
supplémentaires démultiplier et à la
monétisation des rtt c'est là encore une
nouvelle façon de ne pas répondre à la
nécessité d'augmenter la rémunération du
travail de revaloriser le smic et les
salaires en suggérant à ceux et celles
qui le peuvent de travailler plus pour
tenter de garder la tête hors de l'eau
je proverbe sarkozyste vieilles recettes
libérales deuxième vieilles lunes au
passage que de remettre en cause les 35
heures tout l'objet du texte et l'a
évité le sujet central du salaire et
continuer à défendre la modération
salariale et la dégradation de la
cotisation sociale les exonérations
grimpe d'un étage à chaque étape c'est
un cercle vicieux où la dégradation des
conditions de travail et des conditions
de vie nourry l'affaiblissement de la
sécurité sociale qui sera utile à
justifier de nouvelles régressions
demain
j'en veux pour preuve également cet
épisode pour tout dire désolant qui a vu
le gouvernement demandé à l'assemblée de
revenir sur son vote concernant une
revalorisation des pensions et des
minima sociaux qu'ils seraient alignées
sur l'augmentation des prix vous avez
donc résolument fait le choix de sourds
revaloriser les retraites et de dégrader
une nouvelle fois le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités j'en veux pour preuve encore
la façon dont vous accrocher à cette
prime virtuel qu'un nombre restreint de
salarié touchera comme si elle était une
solution avec des aides publiques non
ciblés et versées sans condition dans le
cadre qu'un des plafonnements aux
apparences spectaculaire c'est donc la
république des apparences le sénat avait
néanmoins la sagesse de vous alerter sur
quelques hypocrisie trop visibles comme
cette dénomination impropre de prime de
partage de la valeur quand vous
souhaitez
si peu si peu une autre répartition des
richesses il pointe est aussi l'oncle
incongruité de la menace de fusion des
branches comme levier pour que celle-ci
négocié au 1er août une majorité des
branches conserve des minima au dessous
du smic vous êtes en train de fabriquer
un pays de bas salaires un pays où le
travail est mal reconnus mal rémunérés
pour une trop large part de femmes et
d'hommes nombre de travailleurs de
travailleuses vivent mal de leur travail
on nous explique en permanence qu'il
faut s'attaquer au coût du travail vous
n'osez plus d'ailleurs le dire si fort
mais vous faites tout pour
nous explique qu'il faut gagner la
course effrénée à la compétitivité qui
créé tant de souffrance au travail mais
quand quand allez vous vous attaquez au
coût du capital au coût de la finance au
coût des mesures au cours de la
spéculation quand allez vous vous
attaquez au coût social et
environnemental de cette folle course au
profit de ce creusement permanent des
inégalités on nous explique également
que la modération salariale permettrait
de juguler l'inflation nous nous le
vérifions pas par les temps qui courent
la modération salariale pèse sur le
quotidien et sur la nature de notre
développement et elle permet à la
finance de prospérer sans limite c'était
une occasion d'agir face à l'inflation
qui n'a pas comme c'est hier et votre
loi au lieu de conforter le pouvoir
d'achat protègent le pouvoir d'achat
celui de la finance enfin les mesures
que vous prenez sur le volet énergétique
continue à affaiblir edf alors que vous
nous aurions tant besoin d'un service
public de l'énergie est trahi cette
absence d'anticipation et de
planification unis nation qui vous
conduit aujourd'hui à prendre des
mesures qui s'affranchissent de
garanties environnementales et de
sécurité au havre vous admettez par
ailleurs l'importation de gaz de schiste
nous nous y opposons au bout du compte
corps et vous fait vraiment pour le
pouvoir d'achat ce que vous aurez fait
est au mieux insuffisant au pire
nuisibles pendant ce temps nombre de
femmes et d'hommes nombre de familles
vivent mal dans notre pays il ya des
minots qui passe devant des boulangeries
et qui n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
résister alors il faudrait une loi pour
le pouvoir d'achat ce serait une loi de
progrès social
la parole est à monsieur pas londres et
colombani pour le groupe libertés
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
madame la présidente
dans la ministre monsieur le ministre
mme la présidente de commission madame
en porter
chers collègues
avec cette loi allons-nous suffisamment
amélioré le quotidien de cette ceux qui
souffrent de ces messieurs qui voient
leur facture grimper et leurs salaires
stagner c'est la seule question qui
prévaut où le coût de la vie est telle
que c'est la seule vraie question qui
prévaut à l'heure où le coût de la vie
est telle qu'il empêche les personnes de
vivre dignement du fruit de leur travail
or du travail et plus particulièrement
de sa valorisation au travers des
salaires il en est finalement que peu
question vous faites le choix de
dispositif facultatif qui ne profiteront
pas tous d'abord l'après la
pérennisation de la prime pouvoir
d'achat le doublement de son plafond
relève presque de la communication
jusqu'ici cette prime n'a été en moyenne
que 2 540 euros loin des 6000 euros
affichés et quatre salariés sur cinq
n'ont pour le moment pas bénéficié
je voulais faire les mêmes remarques sur
les mesures introduites au sénat sur ce
texte et dans le budget rectificatif
réduction des cotisations associés aux
heures supplémentaires ou encore rachat
de rtt
ces dispositions peuvent dans l'urgence
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat mais elle ne
constitue pas une politique salariale il
faudra donc rapidement avoir ce débat
essentiel celui de la juste rémunération
du travail si nous nous déroberons à ce
débat il se rappellera à nous de la même
manière il ne nous faudra pas nous
dérober du débat sur la pérennité d'un
autre modèle social je rappelle que si
le pays a comparativement à ses voisins
mieux encaisser le choc inflationniste
c'est grâce à ses amortisseurs sociaux
le pérenniser le conforter c'est
proposer de nouvelles sources de
financement la taxe exceptionnelle des
superprofits de certains grands groupes
étaient une réponse juste nous
regrettons qu'elle ait été rejetée
encore une fois je pose la question le
projet de loi améliorera la vie concrète
des gens disons qu'il limitera les
débats les dégâts les revalorisations de
prestations sociales à 4 % demeurent en
deçà de l'inflation le gouvernement
s'est engagé au banc à revaloriser les
retraites en fonction de l'inflation dès
janvier prochain nous suivrons la
concrétisation de cette promesse
de la même manière il faudra mieux
adaptée il faut il faudra faire mieux
pour adapter les mesures aux
spécificités territoriales source
d'inégalités notre groupe a permis
quelques petites avancées en matière de
logement pour contenir la hausse des
loyers à 2,5 dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et 1,5 pour cent en corse
dans ces territoires les tensions sur le
marché locatif sont particulièrement
fortes mais soyons lucides beaucoup de
locataires continueront à dédier une
part excessive de leur revenu à se loger
c'est aussi un débat auquel nous ne
pourrons pas échapper il n'est pas
normal que nos concitoyens ne puisse
tout simplement pas accéder à un
logement à un prix raisonnable à
proximité leur travail et malgré notre
proposition l'adaptation des mesures de
soutien aux spécificités territoriales
reste insuffisante on ne vit pas
pourtant la même vague inflationniste
de la même manière à paris en corse en
zone rurale ou dans les outre-mer où la
situation est très difficile
un satisfécit tout de même là des congés
ganisation de du calcul de l'allocation
d'adulte handicapé c'est l'aboutissement
du combat que nous menons de longue date
et j'ai une pensée pour notre ancien
collègue jeanine dubié aux gourmets au
gouvernement désormais au gouvernement
désormais d'assumer d'assurer une mise
en oeuvre rapide de cette mesure de
justice un mot enfin des mesures
relatives aux prix d'énergie elles sont
stratégiques puisque en grande partie
l'infraction en résulte le choix qui est
fait est encore celui d'urgence au
détriment du climat réouverture des
centrales à charbon terminal méthanier
méthanier flottant importations de gaz
de schiste ces décisions d'urgence
doivent rester dérogatoire et ponctuel
une alerte également sur la situation
d'edf vous proposer un rachat du capital
non détenus par l'état pourquoi pas mais
cela ne résout en rien le déficit
abyssal d'edf creusé par d'autres que
creuser entre autres par la reine
la décision de réhausser les prix de
l'électricité vendue par edf à ses
concurrents tout en limitant la quantité
cd va dans le bon sens mais cela reste
insuffisant toutefois pour libérer les
marges financières
entretenir le parc dr investir dans la
transition écologique transition
écologique qui était la grande absente
ce texte
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues améliorons nous la vie
des gens voilà la question qui se
prévaut au moment de ce vote
malgré les critiques nous reconnaissions
quelques avancées nous nous y opposons
pas une partie des députés de mon groupe
soutiendra une autre partie s'abstiendra
merci
la parole est à madame christine le
nabour pour le groupe renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames la
rapporteure chers collègues je tiens
d'abord à saluer les accords issus de
des discussions en commission mixte
paritaire le parlement a bien été au
rendez vous pour apporter des solutions
rapides pour le pouvoir d'achat des
françaises et des français chers
collègues nous pouvons être fiers
forts de nos discussions sur ces bancs
parfois jusqu'à l'aube nous avons réussi
à trouver des compromis ensemble les
compromis qui répondent à l'urgence et
s'inscrivent dans une logique commune
celle d'une politique ambitieuse que
nous portons pour continuer à améliorer
le quotidien des français face au
contexte actuel de la crise sanitaire et
de la guerre en ukraine confronté à une
inflation inédite depuis 1985 nous avons
dû agir rapidement et avec efficacité
en amont de ce projet de loi porté par
le gouvernement nous avons su préserver
notre économie protéger nos entreprises
et nos salariés
les résultats sont bien au rendez vous
notre économie résiste le taux d'emploi
est au plus haut depuis 25 ans c'est
fort de ces résultats que nous devons
continuer à construire ensemble nous
avons agi en responsabilité avec cette
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
chers collègues quels sont aujourd'hui
les préoccupations de nos concitoyens
avoir un emploi avoir plus de pouvoir
d'achat payer moins d'impôts que le
travail paie plus que les retraites
soient plus conséquente oui ce texte
répond à l'urgence de la situation et
bien à l'ensemble des préoccupations de
nos compatriotes
oui en votant ce texte nous allons
permettre que le travail paie toujours
mieux nous transformons la prime
maquereau en prime de partage de la
valeur et nous la pérennisons nous
baissons les cotisations sociales pour
les travailleurs indépendants airs
valises revalorisons la prime d'activité
de 4% nous créons une réduction
cotisations patronales au titre des
heures supplémentaires pour les
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
l'article 3 traduit la volonté du
gouvernement de prolonger l'effort
réalisé depuis 2010 est en faveur de la
diffusion de l'intéressement dans les
petites et moyennes entreprises reese il
est peu répandu dans nos pme nous
continuons donc de l'encourager par la
simplification et l'assouplissement des
règles qui l'encadrent deux articles ont
été introduits au sénat qui vise à
développer de manière anticipée les
sommes accumulées au titre de la
participation et de l'intéressement
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2022 est autorisée
hinx exceptionnellement et jusqu'au 31
décembre 2000 23 l'utilisation des
titres restaurant pour l'achat de tout
produit alimentaire qu'ils soient ou non
directement consommables par ce texte
nous protégeons le pouvoir d'achat des
plus vulnérables des retraités et des
étudiants pour que personne ne soit
laissé de côté nous sommes pas tous
égaux face à l'inflation c'est pourquoi
nous valorisons de 4% les retraites de
base le smic mais également toutes les
prestations sociales les bourses
étudiantes sont également concernés par
ailleurs nous inciterons les branches
professionnelles à garantir des minima
conventionnels au niveau du smic la
faiblesse du nombre d'accords pourrait
entraîner une possible restructuration
nous avons acté la dea conjugale isation
de l'allocation adulte handicapé au plus
tard au 1er octobre 2023 le revenu du
conjoint ne sera plus pris en compte
dans le calcul une action qui sera
favorable à plus de 160 mille ménages en
couple parce que là des conjugale
isation pénalise les personnes en
situation d'handicap qui travaillent
dont le conjoint ou la conjointe ne
travaille pas nous avons voté pour un
dispositif qui désorientera
automatiquement vers le système de
calcul le plus favorable ceci en
fonction de leur situation personnelle
et professionnelle nous intervenons
directement sur le prix de l'énergie et
des loyers le bouclier tarifaire qui a
permis selon l'insee et de réduire
l'inflation significativement sera par
ailleurs complété par la limitation à
3,5 pour cent des augmentations de loyer
enfin nous protégeons les consommateurs
face aux abus contractuels nous allons
rendre plus simple la résiliation des
contrats d'assurance et certains
abonnements en quelques clics seulement
et pour tous protéger le pouvoir d'achat
des français c'est aussi les protéger
des arnaques tout en simplifiant les
systèmes d'abonnement chers collègues ce
texte privilégient des mesures
temporaires et ciblées en responsabilité
car nous ne pouvons pas nous affranchir
d'une bonne gestion budgétaire vis-à-vis
des générations futures le retour de
l'inflation et la progression des taux
d'intérêt ont replacé au premier plan la
question de la dette et du déficit
public ainsi la stratégie est claire
protéger les français sans augmenter les
impôts et sans augmenter
considérablement le mans la dette la
crise que nous vivons est différente des
crises passées la hausse du taux
d'emploi et la baisse du chômage nous
conforte dans l'idée de poursuivre notre
action en faveur de la croissance
durable et du travail améliorer la vie
quotidienne des français et atteindre le
plein emploi j'ose espérer que les
françaises et les français sauront faire
la différence entre ceux dans cet
hémicycle qui voteront contre ce texte
qui ont décidé de nier le parle le
travail parlementaire qui ont décidé de
ne rien faire pour le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens qui ont décidé de
refuser tout simplement de les aider est
ce qu'ils vont voter ce texte en
responsabilité qui n'ont qu'un objectif
celui de palier à l'urgence de la
situation
protéger les françaises et les français
face aux conséquences de l'inflation
le groupe renaissance votre à ce texte
je vous remercie
et avant de donner la parole aux
prochains orateurs et dernier orateur
inscrit je vous rappelle que la
conférence des président des présidents
a décidé qu'il serait procédé à un
scrutin public sur le projet de loi
contenu du texte de la commission mixte
paritaire je fais d'ores et déjà annoncé
le scrutin dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale dernier orateur
monsieur victor cateau pour le groupe
rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis ici pour discuter des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat cette commission mixte paritaire
était à l'image de ce qui se fait de
mieux au théâtre à savoir la mise en
scène d'un accord implicite entre les
députés et des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle et des républicains alors
que retiendront nous de cette commission
un fait notoire tout d'abord les acteurs
n'ont pas écrit la pièce certes ils ont
correctement su réciter leur texte mais
ils n'auront même pas fait l'effort de
cacher le fait que tout était joué
d'avancé
jo est à un rythme effréné ce simulacre
de débat parlementaire
se sera tenu que par nécessité
institutionnels ainsi mes chers
collègues je regrette qu'à aucun moment
la possibilité de faire valoir la
position de chacun ne nous étaient
délaissées élu de la république
parlementaire nous députés et sénateurs
n'avons pas été élus pour jouer un rôle
dans une mauvaise pièce de théâtre mais
bel et bien pour représenter les
françaises les français et les
aspirations légitimes et ce d'autant
plus s'agissant d'un texte aussi
essentiel pour répondre à leur première
préoccupation le pouvoir d'achat
ainsi je me risque à dire que dans ce
procédé il ya quelque chose de
profondément dérangeant alors que la
voix des vraies oppositions et non pas
celle d opposition de façade n'a pas pu
être entendue lors de cette commission
par ce procédé donc la minorité
présidentielle ayant reçu l'aide
providentielle des républicains aura
tout loisir d'écarter de la négociation
finale le premier groupe d'opposition le
rassemblement national
étrange procédé lorsqu'on sait que
l'esprit même d'une commission mixte
paritaire et de surmonter les
divergences politiques afin d'aboutir à
un texte commun historiquement il
conviendra donc de rappeler que c'est
notre parti qui a été le précurseur sur
la question de la déconvenue ganisation
de la halle de l'allocation adulte
handicapé que c'est notre parti qui a
été précurseur en matière de
disponibilité du plan des bandes
salariale que c'est notre parti qui
avait des précurseurs concédant
l'extension de l'utilisation des tickets
restaurants mais aussi et surtout que
c'est notre candidate marine le pen qui
a été la première à mettre le sujet du
pouvoir d'achat sur la table
c'est évidemment la preuve
que c'est sur nos bancs que devrait
siéger les députés les sénateurs qui
oeuvrent pour notre pays avec bon sens
néanmoins il est intéressant de rappeler
mes chers collègues que son nombre de
sujets nous avons proposé vous avez
repris nos idées et vous avez voté pour
en outre il convient également de
souligner la complicité de la minorité
présidentielle et de l'opposition de
façade des républicains avec
l'extrême-gauche nubes pour déclarer nos
amendements y recevra parfois et pour
les rejeter souvent permettez moi de
vous dire que ce faisant vous marchez
tout droit vers la bim de les
responsabilités politiques ainsi par
calcul sans doute il aura suffi que nos
propositions soient reprises par un
autre groupe parlementaire pour que la
magie opère et vous fasse réaliser tout
le bon sens de nos positions au fond
nous l'essentiel ce sont les
propositions qui aboutissent pour être
tout à fait sincère avec vous ce jeu
mesquin ne fera que vous affaiblir
quoi qu'il en soit je dois le souligner
nous nous félicitons malgré tout du
travail accompli en ce début de 7e
législature des avancées ont pu être
réalisés même si il reste beaucoup à
faire si la gauche ayant perdu sa
boussole a préféré jeter en bloc ce
texte nous assumons quant à nous de
soutenir ces petits pas nous serons
toujours là tant son ancien conscription
qu'à l'assemblée nationale pour
améliorer jour après jour le quotidien
des françaises et des français enfin et
j'en terminerai par là avec notre groupe
du rassemblement national nous avons eu
nous n'avons eu cesse de proposer les
amendements de bon sens des amendements
qui améliore le pouvoir d'achat des
françaises et des français pourtant il
semblerait que cette attitude
constructive de responsabilité
d'ouverture qui sera notre leitmotiv
durant toute cette législature ne soient
pas partagés ni pas ni par la main la
minorité présidentielle ni par le
gouvernement ni par exxon gauche du ps
sans doute préféré vous prêt mais vos
calculs politiciens sur l'intérêt des
français mais cela ne sera jamais notre
cas compter sur eux pour en être juge
jour merci
je vous remercie
la discussion générale est close nous en
venions au texte de la commission mixte
paritaire conformément à l'article 113
alinéa 3 du règlement je vais appeler
l'assemblée a statué d'abord sur les
amendements dont je suis saisi trois
amendements du gouvernement un
amendement numéro un monsieur ministre
merci madame la présidente il
à la présidente si vous me le permettez
je peux présenter les trois amendements
commercial expression il s'agit comme je
l'indiquais trois amendements visant à
lever le gage sur des dispositions
adoptées par la cmp de manière à ce que
le financement des mesures soient
assurés sans êtres assurer aux dépens
d'autres lignes budgétaires je remercie
monsieur le ministre avez vous voir
amener la commission très bien je vais
donc mettre successivement voit ces
amendements de mon numéro un avec avis
favorable de la commission qui est pour
et qui est contre
l'amendement est adopté un moment numéro
2 mais ma vie qui est pour et qui est
contre
adopté un amendement numéro 3 mais ma
vie même vote
je vais donc mettre voix le projet de
loi contenu du texte de la commission
mixte paritaire modifié par les
amendements qui vient d'être adoptée
merci de regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votants 543 exprimé
507 majorité 254 pour 395 contre 112
l'assemblée a adopté le projet de loi
[Applaudissements]